think about everything you touch in a
day now think about how much of it is
plastic plastics are amazing materials
they're lightweight but strong flexible
but impermeable they're in our cars
planes hospitals weapons and electronics
plastic is everywhere but of course
that's the problem plastic is everywhere
more importantly plastics don't
biodegrade that water bottle you use for
ten minutes it could take 500 years or
more to fully decomposed most plastics
that we use are single-use short time
use packaging and then they're discarded
that mismatch between plastics short use
and long life results in an overflow of
plastic waste think about how crazy this
is to get the raw materials for plastics
we spend billions pulling fossil fuels
out of the earth then we pollute the
earth to make plastics and then we toss
those plastics right back into the
ground where they came from I think 50
years from now what will happen is
people will be digging out land fields
and taking out product to recycle and
they will think we were crazy people of
dumping things in landfills
so we should just get rid of plastic
small problem there is nothing better at
doing what plastic does than plastic
when it comes to its low cost
versatility and durability the plastic
we use today is unbeatable we're not
going to get rid of plastics anytime
soon so we better deal with them in a
more intelligent way from where they
come from and also where they go after
we're done using them that means two
things we have to develop new
environmentally friendly materials that
can replace petroleum-based plastics and
we have to find a way to clean up the
plastics we've already discarded
one of the team's that's developing a
sustainable replacement for plastic is
here in this lab at the Center for
sustainable polymers at the University
of Minnesota the majority of plastics
that we use now are from petroleum and
by majority I mean more than 90 percent
maybe more than 95 but the team at this
lab is trying to change that they are
trying to totally rethink where a
plastic can come from could you make a
plastic of living materials like plants
or bacteria one of the common
misconceptions in the world of plastic
is that there's plastic well actually
there's several different varieties of
plastic you familiar with recycling
symbols there's seven of those so
there's no one plastic that will replace
all plastics at the lab researchers are
working on several types of bio plastics
that's plastic made out of renewable
resources that could be used for
everything from the soles of shoes to
housing insulation the latest
breakthrough is a new type of foam that
could replace petroleum-based cushioning
like what's in car seats and bedding and
it all starts with bacteria it's eco
life its STD check life so that's the
strain that we use for our experiments
the e.coli is genetically modified
meaning it's given a new set of
instructions in this case to synthesize
molecules that can be polymerized to
create new materials then they're fed
sugar shaken and fermented the byproduct
of this process is a molecule that's a
precursor to plastic when mixed with a
catalyst in the lab the chemical
reaction produces this bubbling gel-like
substance when it hardens
you've got foam
so it's still pretty sticky but this can
then be cut and thrown into pillows the
main reason that I think this is
important is because the feedstock is
renewable there's an endless supply of
bacteria and sugar a far cry from
petroleum which is limited in supply and
expensive to find so that's where the
foam comes from but what happens when
it's time to throw it away when you're
ready to get rid of that car seat or
pillow most phones aren't recycled and
if they are they're chopped up and
broken into a degraded material but if
this foam is collected it can be
chemically broken back down into the
same precursor they started with which
can then be used to create new foams
over and over again the lab is also
working on a replacement for rubber in
things like shoes tires sporting
equipment or household items so we want
to look for rubbery materials things
that are stretchy that are elastic that
can be extended and they snap right back
this process starts with starch from
corn chemists can synthesize the polymer
in the lab dry it and then mold it once
we form some of the rubbers that we use
today
we can't reprocess them they can just be
ground up and make the playground rubber
material but this you can melt and
reprocess and reuse it and it's
compostable that's what we strive for
right because we don't want to have our
ocean filled with process
so why aren't materials like this in all
of our couches and shoes already so I
oftentimes joke that my lab has produced
a lot of materials that have interesting
and exciting properties but nobody
really cares about him that's because
the bio plastics in this lab are still
relatively expensive to produce
especially now with oil prices so low
the unfortunate reality is that
consumers like you will not pay a
premium for bio renewability
or degradability they're not much of a
premium an ideal bioplastic would not
only look and perform as well as
petroleum-based plastics it would be
just as cheap and easy to produce it
probably won't look any different I'll
still grab the bag to put my fruit at
the grocery store
except it'll be from bio-based
feedstocks and except when I throw it
away it'll have a facile route to
decomposition to give environmentally
innocuous byproducts
if this lab succeeds a better world
might look a lot like the one we already
live in bio plastics may be a few years
out but there are steps we can take
today to help clean up the plastic we've
already used we're at carbon light
industries in Riverside California
it's a plastics recycling plant one that
specializes in recycling a type of
plastic called PE tea that you find in
most soda and water bottles every day
300,000 pounds of plastic bottles arrive
in bales that's 3 billion bottles a year
they're sent through a maze of high-tech
machines that sort clean melt and
sanitize them
it's what you think of when you think of
a recycling plant except carbon light
does something few recyclers are
actually able to do turn plastic bottles
back into material for new plastic
bottles this is Leon Ferran ik founder
and CEO of carbon light by the way
Leon's been in plastics for a long time
he ran one of the first companies that
introduced plastic bags to grocery
stores in the 80s I feel that ok I
brought grocery sacks and all that now
I'm what do you call it redeeming myself
and I'm doing recycling until recently
most plastic bottles collected for
recycling in the US were sent overseas a
lot of the bottles that was collected in
California for example or other places
were being shipped to China so what the
Chinese would do take the bottles
transform it into a lesser material like
a carpet like fabric and then ship it
back to us bottle to bottle like what we
do that we call it cradle to cradle that
that happens a lot less what most people
don't realize is when they throw a
plastic water bottle into a blue or
green recycling bin that bottles less
likely to become another bottle than it
is to become something else
like carpet or teddy bear stuffing and
if it winds up living a second life as
carpeting or teddy bear stuffing then it
more than likely ends it's recyclable
life there that's because those
materials are harder to collect and
recycle why not just turn old plastic
bottles into new ones well it's
expensive and you have to have a very
sophisticated facility like this one to
be able to make the necessary material
for people to use it for their beverages
Jeff Walsh vice president of operations
took us around to show us the inner
workings ok so this is where the process
starts
one of these bales weighs about 1300
pounds or so first bottles are broken
out of bales trash and non PE tea
materials are separated using optical
sorters then a rinse cycle begins to
remove labels and camps colored and
clear materials are separated then they
get crushed and hot washed finally the
bottles are ground into what carbon
light calls cornflake the last step is
melting the flake and cutting it into
beads Jose VA is the Quality Control
Manager at the on-site lab we operate 24
hours a day seven days a week and our
sole purpose is to test the lab tests
the product to make sure it meets
manufacturer's standards for safety and
structural integrity with the most
recent dip in oil prices Ferran ik says
plastics derived from petroleum are
currently cheaper than carbon lights
recycled material even so customers like
Nestle and Pepsi still buy carbon
light's product to use in some of their
bottles after all who doesn't like to
see an earth-friendly logo on their 15
ounces of acai machine this is our
problem it will be ashame to 50 years
from now people are suffering this is
right for the environment it's really a
huge issue and we have to take care of
it